TELLS THEM THE TRUTH.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE
>> JOINING US NOW CHARLIE HURT
WASHINGTON TIMES OPINION EDITOR,
AND BEN, EDITOR AT LARGE FOR THE
SPECTATOR BOTH FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTE TOURS AND HERE IN NEW
YORK
>> CHARLIE FROM CENSORSHIP AND
MEDIA, THEY'RE NOT TURNING DOWN
THE TEMPERATURE IN THIS RACE ONE
BIT BUT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
BOTH.
>> OH, YEAH, NO, AND THEY REALLY
AREN'T.
WE'VE GOTTEN THIS SORT OF
STRANGE THING WHERE WE HAVE THE
PRE ELECTION ELECTION DENYING
WHICH I THINKS IS A FIRST.
BUT THE OTHER THING -- OBVIOUSLY
POLITICIANS ALWAYS SORT OF SHADE
THE TRUTH AND DON'T ALWAYS SPEAK
HONESTLY.
BUT WHAT IS SO ALARMING, WHAT'S
SO ASTOUNDING ABOUT THIS IS TO
LISTEN TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, AND TO LISTEN TO
THESE DEMOCRATS LIE TO PEOPLE'S
FACES AND TELL THEM WHAT THEY
KNOW IS GOING ON IN THEIR OWN
PERSONAL LIVES IS NOT GOING.
NOT ONLY DOES IT BEE LITTLE
THOSE PEOPLE BUT IT ALSO
COMPLETELY DESTROYS THEIR
CREDIBLE.
I AGREE WITH YOU I THINK THIS IS
A GREAT REALIGNMENT BUT I THINK
IT'S MORE THAN THIS.
I THINK WHAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING
TO THE PAL DID PARTY RIGHT NOW
AND WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE DOING TO
THAT PARTY RIGHT NOW IS A
GENERATIONAL DAMAGE THAT COULD
TAKE TEN YEARS, COULD TAKE
DECADES FOR THEM TO RECOVER.
BECAUSE NOBODY BELIEVES WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING ANYMORE.
>> Laura: THAT IS EXCELLENT
POINT.
NOW, BEN, THE BIG NEWS TODAY OUT
OF PENNSYLVANIA WAS THAT THE
FETTERMAN CAMPAIGN IS NOW SUING
TO HAVE UNDATED AND MISDATED
BALLOTS COUNTED.
APPARENTLY SOME AREN'T SIGNED
EITHER.
NOW THEY ARGUE THE HANDWRITTEN
DATE REQUIREMENT IS JUST A
TECHNICALITY AND IN ORDER USED
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE VOTES
WERE LEGALLY CAST AND THROWING
THEM ALL OUT VIOLATES FEDERAL
CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS.
BEN, THIS IS ANOTHER DESPERATE
MOVE ON THE PART OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> YES, BUT IT'S ALSO TOTALLY
PREDICTABLE.
I MEAN THEY'RE COMPLETELY
HYPOCRITES ON ALL THIS STUFF.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK, AND THIS IS SUCH A GREAT
POINT THAT CHARLIE JUST MADE,
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF WHAT WE'RE
SEEING GOING ON, THE REALIGNMENT
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT A SWEEPING AWAY OF
A GENERATION OF DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP THAT HAS DOMINATED IN
WASHINGTON.
IT HAS CONTROLLED AND DIRECTED
THEIR PARTY.
AND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE IS
NOT JUST THEM SWEPT AWAY BUT A
WHOLE GROUP OF GEN-X'ers
SUPPOSED TO TAKE THE REIGNS
SWEPT AWAY.
PEOPLE LIKE TIM RYAN.
BETO O'ROURKE I WENT AND
CALCULATED $200 MILLION HAS BEEN
SPENT ON PAY 0 BETO O'ROURKE,
IT'S NOT HAPPYING.
STACEY ABRAMS IS GOING TO GET
COMPLETELY SWEPT AWAY BY BRIAN
KEMP.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
IS WE ARE MOVING TO A DEMOCRAT
PARTY THAT IS LED BY MILLENNIAL
GIRL BOSS TYPES AND THAT IS
CRAZY TOWN IN WHAT THEY OFFER TO
THE COUNTRY AND WHAT THEY SAY.
AS MUCH AS I THINK YOU HAD THIS
WHOLE FALSE APPROACH BY JOE
BIDEN TO RETURN TO NORMALCY THE
ACTUAL RESULT OF HIS POLICIES
AND THIS TERRIBLE WHITE HOUSE IS
GOING TO BE AN EVEN CRAZIER MORE
LEFTIST DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Laura: AND TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT HOW THE OLD DINOSAURS ARE
KIND OF GOING TO BE PUSHED OFF
THE STAGE OR LUMBER OFF THE
STAGE, NANCY PELOSI WAS ON CNN
TONIGHT BEING INTERVIEWED BY
ANDERSON COOPER.
IT SEEMED LIKE SHE WAS, TO ME,
HER BODY LANGUAGE, ASIDE FROM
THE FACT SHE SAID SHE NEVER
SPOKE ABOUT THE ATTACK WITH HER
HUSBAND, WHICH, THAT WAS AN
INTERESTING COMMENT, BUT SHE
SEEMED LIKE SHE WAS ON HER WAY
OUT, TO ME.
NOT THAT SHE WAS DEFEATED BUT
SHE WAS GOING TO LEAVE.
THAT WAS MY SENSE.
>> CERTAINLY THE BODY LANGUAGE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT.
BUT THE FACT THAT THEY DON'T
SPEAK OPENLY ABOUT IT, AND I GET
IT,' AHEAD OF THE ELECTION SO
MAYBE IT'S SORT OF DIFFICULT,
BUT IT GOES TO THE HEART OF, YOU
KNOW, DESTROYING THAT, WHATEVER
CREDIBILITY THEY HAVE LEFT.
HONESTLY, I REALLY DON'T -- HOW
ARE THEY GOING TO RESPOND TO
THIS ELECTION?
ARE THEY GOING TO LEARN A
LESSON?
NO.
>> THAT'S THE THING NO LESSONS
WILL BE LEARNED.
>> Laura: NONE.
>> THEY HAVE CONVINCED
THEMSELVES WE ARE HAVING THIS
MORALE STANDUP THING IN DEFENSE
OF DEMOCRACY AND IT'S JUST A
BUNCH OF FASCISTS AND RACISTS
COMING TO BEAT THEM.
THE PROBLEM OF COURSE IS THIS IS
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE COALITIONS REPUBLICANS
HAVE EVER FORMED.
>> Laura: THE TALKING POINTS
DON'T WORK ANYMORE.
>> NO ONE BELIEVES THAT.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU SEE
THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK COME
OUT AND SAY IT'S JUST HYSTERICAL
TO COMPLAIN ABOUT CRIME, YOU
KNOW, BLACK, HISPANIC AND ASIAN
AMERICANS IN THESE NEW YORK
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE SEEN THE
INCREASES IN CRIME KNOW THAT
THAT'S A LIE, THEY SEE RIGHT
THROUGH IT ANT THEY AREN'T GOING
TO BE CALLED RACIST BECAUSE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY POINTING IT
OUT.
>> Laura: CHARLIE WE TALKED
ABOUT HOW POLITICIANS TEND TO
LOSE THEIR MOJO OVER TIME WHEN
THEY STAY IN THE GAME TOO LONG.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SAY THIS
ABOUT OBAMA BUT WE PLAYED A
LITTLE BIT ON THE ANGLE BUT HE
DROPPED A PARTICULARLY UNHINGED
LINE OVER THE WEEKEND.
WATCH.
>> WHEN TRUE DEMOCRACY GOES AWAY
PEOPLE GET HURT.
IT HAS REAL CONSEQUENCES.
THIS IS NOT AN AND STRACK SHUNS,
DIS DENTS START GETTING LOCKED
UP REPORTERS GET LOCKED UP IF
THEY'RE NOT TOWING THE PARTY
LINE.
CORRUPTION REIGNS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Laura: HE WAS SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE HE WAS ABLE TO KEEP THE
FAR LEFT AT BAY, REMEMBER FOR
TRADITIONAL MARRIAGE, THE OLD
DAYS OF OBAMA.
HE KEPT THEM A LITTLE BIT AT
ARM'S LENGTH BUT NOW IT IS HE'S
SUCH A LIAR.
BARACK OBAMA WOULD NEVER HAVE
RUN ON THE CAMPAIGN JOE BIDEN
HAS RUN AND NEVER WOULD HAVE WON
REELECTION EXCEPT THAT -- YOU
KNOW, HIS 2008 CAMPAIGN WAS A
BRILLIANT CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS HOPEFUL.
ABOUT YOU FROM THAT MOMENT ON,
IT HAS BEEN DARKNESS AND
DISHONESTY FROM HIM.
IN THE CLIP YOU PLAYED EARLIER
WHERE HE'S TALKING ABOUT IF WE
HAD THE MAJORITY IN 2014.
THEY HAD A FILIBUSTER PROOF
MAJORITY FOR TWO YEARS AT THE
BEGINNING OF HIS TERM.
IF HE WANTED TO FIX IMMIGRATION
HE COULD HAVE DONE IT, THEY
COULD HAVE DONE ANYTHING THEY
WANTED TO TO AND THEY FAILED.
>> AND THEY DIDN'T WANT TO, THEY
WANTED TO KEEP THE ISSUE.
>> AND THEY WANTED TO TAKE A SIX
OF THE ECONOMY.
>> Laura: IT'S LIKE AN OLD
LOUNGE ACT, LIKE IMAGINE IF I
WAS STILL -- IT WAS LIKE SPINAL
TAP.
IMAGINE IF THE STADIUM WAS STI